Hello freaks.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by Ting Tang
has a a new thing going on right now as we speak.
There's a new contest going on where they're giving away an iPhone five to one
lucky Joe Rogan podcast listener.
To enter,
go to rogan.ting.com fill out the savings calculator and see how much you'd save
using Ting tweet,
how much you'd save two at Joe Rogan with the Hashtag Ting.
That's like the little pound sign.
It used to be pound,
pound Tang and the winner will be announced Friday,
April 4th u s residents only.
Very ironic for those who live in Canada cause although ting is an awesome cell
phone company,
it doesn't work in Canada.
It works in Canada,
but he can't like live in Canada and buy it.
I don't know why.
I don't understand anything.
What his tank tank is a no bullshit cell phone service.
What they have is a sprint backbone.
They use sprint,
they rent time on the sprint network,
but they do it all their way with no contracts,
no early termination fees,
no a bundling or ride along services.
The rates are what?
The way it works is you pay for what you use.
If you use more,
you pay more.
If you use less,
you pay less.
98% of people who would use Tang would save money.
That's straight from their website.
So it must be true.
I've done no research of my own to verify this,
but I have friends that use it.
Chris Ryan uses it,
he loves it.
Uh,
I know several people that I've met from doing the podcast.
Then use Tang,
love the service and love the fact they save a shitload of money.
Go to rogan.ting.com and you can save 25 bucks off of your first ting device.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com that's o.
N N.
I.
T.
Lots of new shit going on with on it.
I have a secret but I can't tell you.
We've got a lot of shit happening.
But what on it is is a human optimization website,
but we sell is essentially all the different things that I use as far as like
strength and conditioning equipment like kettle bells or or a club bells or
battle ropes,
all things for developing functional strength.
All the different supplements that we've found that we find beneficial,
whether it's Alpha brain,
which is a competent Tory nootropic or shroom tech sport,
which is a an endurance supplement based on the court accepts mushroom.
All the different supplements have science behind them.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com you can read all the references.
There's been a clinical test recently that we just did on Alpha brain.
The double blind placebo test showed positive results.
The,
although the lab results are available,
but on a.com and there's more tests ongoing right now.
One for t plus.
We've got another Alpha brain going on one right now.
Um,
these are controversial supplements cause a lot of people think,
well wait a minute,
brain supplements of food for your brain,
it actually makes you smarter.
Get the fuck out of here.
It's like a big deck pill.
Well,
it's not the,
the,
the science behind it has been around for a long time and all the references and
all the information and data behind it.
Is that on at.com we also offer a 100% money back guarantee for 90 days.
And the first 30 pills,
you buy a bottle,
try it.
You don't even have to bring it back.
You don't have to send it in.
You just say it sucked and you get your money back.
The reason why we do that is because first of all,
we don't want anybody to feel ripped off.
These are controversial supplements in the beginning,
in the first place,
and two,
because we believe in it.
It's all shit that I use.
I used it long before I started working with on it.
Um,
I've been a fan of nootropics for a long time now.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com O.
N.
I t use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
that's it.
Let's keep it brief.
I haven't curls here running out of time.
Kick.
Cute,
cute.
Jamie,
do it.
Jamie.
Jesus Christ.
Experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Adam Carolla,
I saw you looking for some causes,
coffee with grass fed butter and MCT oil mixed in to,
do you know what that is?
Well,
the idea behind it,
it was a apparently invented two
by a guy named Rob Wolf and then made popular by another guy named Dave Asprey
and what it is is the grass fed butter in the MCT oil provide healthy fats mixed
in with the coffee and a,
it allows a slow burn of the caffeine,
so instead of that big crash that you get,
you don't get the big crash because your body has to absorb the fats that are
blended in with the caffeine.
Yeah,
it's very nice.
It's sweet.
Very nice.
Yeah,
no.
What I do is I simply eat cows that had been fed coffee grounds.
That's a way to do it around them.
Go outside like a Cappuccino,
porterhouse or whatever.
Like instead of the grass fed beef,
I just feed him just straight Sumatra beans straight from a whole foods or
trader Joe's and then I'll eat that cow.
I would go to that steak joint by the way,
the coffee,
just coffee,
fat cow,
bunch of cows all jittery sitting around scratching at their utters and uh,
you know,
scratch scraping themselves up against the fence.
But I would definitely eat that.
That cow sounds like a great idea actually.
I wonder if it would have some sort of effect on the meat.
I don't know,
but I wonder does I'm in man,
I'm into,
let's open it.
Let's do it together.
It's the joint podcast business.
Yeah.
I want to also,
I want to tell me if you're down with this.
Okay.
The best part of going out and eating Italian food is where it's when the chick
comes by with that little silver bucket that has to Parmesan cheese in it,
and she does it with you,
like a little Parmer Shon on that pasta and you go,
fuck yeah,
I'd like a little Parmesan on that pasta.
And she takes the spoon out and she kind of flicks it around the top.
You never quite have the balls to go,
sweetie,
I need a second tip.
Like,
it's that good.
And you go,
yeah,
that's good.
I realize half the time people say you're good.
I'm not good,
but I just say I'm good anyway.
And then she walks away and then you eat the spaghetti but you eat the top,
you take the Parmer Shawn off the top and you get at some point you get down to
the middle and now your permit less.
I would open a restaurant where that bitch came back a second time and it's just
called more Parmer Shon,
it's mediocre Italian food,
but here's the rub.
The chick comes back a second time.
It goes,
can I top off some of that shit that I didn't hit the first
time around?
Your point of diminishing return with cheese,
like the gets to be a point where you don't want half cheese,
half pasta.
That would be a wreck.
No,
but the ratio is too great with the cheese at the beginning and then your cheese
less in the middle to the end.
I just want that last dusting,
just that crop
dust life.
It's more exciting and fascinating in the beginning and the end.
You just sort of maintaining,
yeah.
Are you in maintenance mode?
No,
I'm fine.
Okay,
good.
Good.
I like your digs.
I,
last time I came to your place,
I was at your place and now I'm at your new place.
Yeah,
we got tired of bringing Weirdos over my house after awhile.
No,
I,
I had that with a,
I had Andy Dick come over to my house and devour all of my lunch meats and like
thinly sliced provolone cheese.
You know the stuff you get from the Italian Deli that comes wrapped up in the,
in the paper and the white paper stuff.
Yeah.
And there's a weird thing,
and I don't know how you feel about this,
but I grew up poor and hungry.
Like I was fucking hungry all the time and food was a big deal and I had to Mooc
a lot of food off of other people.
Go to other people's houses and mooch their food at lunch was always bombing,
you know,
hey,
you're going to finish that sandwich,
got eat that sandwich.
You know,
it's like I'll always mooching and bumming Henry's Tacos over here in north
Hollywood when I was a kid.
I should go there and get the broken taco shells.
I'd go,
they make hard shell Tacos,
right?
Yeah.
You got brandy broken shells.
They'd go,
yeah.
Some of them break.
I go give me the broken shells.
They give me the broken shells.
I go give me some hot sauce.
I go,
here's some hot sauce.
It's free.
I got kind of a cup of water,
a cup of water,
not just sitting there eating my own fucking Nachos free.
It sucked.
At the time though,
it was like,
all right,
I'm getting free food.
Uh,
I was always crazy with food and if somebody ever gets into my shit,
I'm okay with it.
But there was some about the lunch meat.
Andy Dick came over and he's like,
you got any cheese,
you got any lunch meat?
And he stood in my kitchen.
He was just taking big handfuls of it and just shoving it in his face.
And then later on when we did the podcast,
he lit up a cigar,
smoked half of it in my office and then kept the other half,
but he never retrieved it and it rolled behind my printer.
And then my house smelled like smoke the lunch meats and smoke cigars and Andy
Dick for the next week.
And I was like,
it's time to move it to the studio.
It's time to go.
It's time to go to the warehouse.
How long ago was this?
I probably,
it's so weird because at the time you don't think to like write anything down.
But I probably started from my Dan in my house and I probably lasted about three
or four months and then I moved it to my
warehouse.
And what year did you start podcasts?
He,
you started right when the radio show was done?
Yeah.
And a February.
Oh nine.
Isn't it funny that that was probably the best thing that could've ever happened
to you?
Is the radio show being done cause that radio show being done,
let you just completely be,
you not worry about nothing,
talk,
say whatever the fuck you want.
And your podcasts became the biggest podcast in the world directly.
As a result of that,
you went right from one right into the other and it became better.
Well,
you know,
uh,
we'd like to get philosophical,
which is what I always take about doing your show.
And everyone spends their life fearful and trying to avoid change and they look
at,
change is a,
is a negative all the time.
Like,
I want to keep my job,
I want to keep my house,
I want to keep my car,
I wanna,
I wanna keep my wife,
I want to keep,
you know,
unless you start making some real cash and then it's time for change.
But what I'm saying is,
you want to,
you should,
we spend our whole lives sort of hanging on to whatever we're hanging on to.
Our youth are whatever,
it's don't change.
And then when somebody gets fired or somebody gets,
you know,
for me,
I tried to be a Groundling and,
and after a certain point,
the Groundling said,
you're not going to make it and you're gone.
And I was heartbroken and devastated.
And I've had girlfriends dumped me and I was heartbroken.
I was Devin,
I had been fired from jobs.
Oh my God.
I had a terrestrial radio GIG and it paid tons of cash and had a big contract
and now you're done.
So you spend your entire life basically fearful and trying to avoid change.
But my question to you is,
when has changed ever been bad?
When is it ever slowed you down?
Is it,
doesn't it just open up other opportunities and can't you look back on your life
at a million times that things have changed and then almost immediately we're
were better after that change.
Sure.
Your girlfriend dumps you and you're bummed out,
beaten off,
and he put tears for six weeks or months and then you meet a hotter chick or
different chick or smarter chick.
You know what I'm saying?
Same with the job.
Same your entire journey of life.
What is no change?
No change is working at the same postal sorting place and Illinois for 41 years.
That's no change.
So even though we're always freaked out by change,
it's usually a good thing.
And it's basically life for them.
Are
the people with the right attitude who do the right things right after a change?
Definitely.
But some people
allow to change to beat the fuck out of them and they never recover.
There's people that got dumped in high school and were never the same human
being afterwards.
There's just people that just never recovered from getting fired from the first
good job they had and then got a pill addiction or whatever the fuck.
There's people that got one divorce and they lost all their money and they
decided to start shrinking.
It is,
fuck this,
I'll throw it all away now.
No,
and I agree and those people need to change and those people,
I mean you ever talked to those dudes that are hanging on to some shit from 20
years ago?
I can't talk to someone who's hanging out with some shift from two weeks ago.
I cut it out.
You know doctor drew,
when he first started doing love line a million years ago,
he worked with a dude called the poor man.
I remember that guy and poor man got himself fired.
I don't know all the ins and outs,
but he sent a bunch of listeners over to being of Kevin and beans house Gay Miss
Address that came out to his lawn.
He Ascot.
Well,
he did a few things that,
you know,
the management wasn't happy when the enemy's him and being or was it just for a
goof?
I think uh,
being with scrolling with poor man and poor man risk grown with being,
but it's like you,
it's like I was tickling you and you are tickling me and then I walked away and
you took a snow shovel and hit me over the head with it and whatever it is,
he crossed the line and it,
at some point the management just went,
well,
we're making a change and a poor man,
you're out and Ricky Rachman you're in and okay.
Ricky Rachman took over and it was doctor drew and Ricky Rachman and poor man
always want a doctor drew to hold out or quit with him or her or whatever he
wanted him to do.
I don't even know all the details.
Now.
Three years later I showed up and I took over for Ricky Rachman.
Uh,
six months ago I was doing one of my,
like Mangria tasting events,
um,
in Manhattan and somebody who was affiliated with the poor man was dispatched to
come to the event and sort of cornered me and hold a microphone in front of me
and say like,
what do you think of the poor man and what do you think a doctor drew and all
that.
And I started thinking to myself,
Jesus fucking Christ,
it's been 20 years.
And when I say 20 years,
I mean 22 years,
I thought,
let it go,
man.
Move onto whatever you're moving on to.
I don't know if you got screwed or you didn't get screwed.
We all get screwed at some point or another.
Move it on.
And I think she said,
is there anything you'd like to,
to poor man?
And by the way,
all I did was fill in,
all I did was take over for the guy who took over for him.
I don't even have any association with him.
And I just said,
may the next 20 years be as fruitful as the last.
Always a good thing to say someone but in context,
yes.
Context.
So I guess some people move on better than others,
but uh,
people,
if you're staring in your rear view mirror and you never stop looking at that
thing and all you want is for that thing to make you whole again,
you just keep driving and get getting further away.
The years just keep wearing on and that thing you're staring on staring at,
I think he's moved on.
Yeah,
patterns of thoughts can be a really good,
if you just one of those guys that develops a really good pattern of thought,
dust yourself off.
All right,
you can fucking keep moving by default and we're going to fucking use this.
It's going to be fuel and from here on how things are going to be way better
because there's no losses.
There's only lessons learned.
Our lesson we're moving on and then there's the other person that by default
fuckin always happens to me.
Man always happens to me,
right?
So tired of the full the world.
Fuck me over.
She leaves me and Roy,
my fucking boss.
Fuck now all the same nonsense.
Love the,
I love the,
why'd you get it
fired?
I got fired because I do the work of five dudes and the boss felt threatened.
Yeah.
Has that ever happened?
No.
I,
I've been the boss a lot of times.
I fired the guy should do the work of half a dude,
not find a nice guy.
You're a nice guy.
There are some people that don't like you doing better than them.
If they're in a position of power,
they will fuck you over
there are always,
you know,
I try,
I say there are always people who are out there to fuck you over.
Just like there,
your chances,
there's a,
there's a chance that you can be hit by a drunk driver when you're just sitting
in an intersection,
you know,
minding your own business.
Just this guy is,
you know,
0.2,
seven five blows through a red lights completely blocked out and just puts you
in a wheelchair or a casket.
I mean,
there is that opportunity that's out there for everyone.
And then there's the chance that you win the lottery.
Or Your Dad is Jerry Jones and owns a professional sports franchise,
and when he dies,
he's going to give the Dallas cowboys to you.
That's not going to be anybody we know.
There'll be the high,
there'll be the low,
almost everyone we know we'll live in the middle and the middle is you get the
Dickhead boss that has it out for you.
You get the girlfriend that dumps you,
cheated on you,
and then you have the best friend who did Jia solid and the boss who was a
really cool guy and the landlord that was cool.
The landlord that is a deck,
you're just going to live in the middle.
So when you,
when you're in the middle and once you've decided you're not blessed,
you're not cursed,
you're just in the middle.
Now you get to control your own own destiny.
I firmly believe that without all those fuck ups,
the honey isn't this sweet.
You have to,
you have to get dumped if you don't get dumped.
If I was still with the same girl that I didn't want to get dumped by when I was
17 my life would be horrifying to be a horrible disaster.
She was,
you know,
we were not compatible.
Right.
Who were you compatible with?
It's that exactly who is compatible with anybody at 17 I wasn't at you think
about it like you hear about these people.
Wow.
You know we're 23 we're going to get married.
I think about where your fucking head was at at 23 Oh god,
no nowhere.
It was in the clouds.
I mean,
I don't even know that guys should be allowed to get married before 30 yeah,
I don't think you can think straight your,
your,
your you,
you first off,
it's amazing that you're an adult and just how fucking stupid you are
when you're 22 or 23 he said,
dude.
Also in terms of your understanding of a woman or giving her what she needs or
responsibility or responsibility,
yourself,
family,
that kind of stuff.
No fucking wise.
Bachelor.
If you don't have a close relationship to some women,
either women that are you're friends with,
he grew up with or preferably sisters or a close relationship with your mother.
You're a guy that grows up with his dad and mom's out of the picture and you're
supposed to learn women.
Good fucking luck.
It's like shelling up in a school in Mexico and try to take first year Spanish.
Yeah,
everybody's fucking way ahead of you man.
They're way ahead of you.
They under like we don't understand each other until deep into our thirties as
far as like men and women kind of understanding it that this other person who
is,
they have a completely different way of thinking.
This is a completely different wiring under the board and you press a button
that you press on a guy and get a positive response and someone's mad at you and
you have to kind of figure out what to say and what not to say and what to tease
about what you can't tease about ever.
I,
when I,
I didn't have a real close relationship with my family,
but when my,
when I was about 19 or 20 I was doing construction.
I was,
you know,
doing construction.
I mean,
I was picking up garbage on a construction site and digging ditches and you
know,
basically just a glorified goop or you know,
like literally you,
you think of it as,
oh,
you're constrained a bunch of guys wearing hard hats and putting together I
beams and girders.
Now it's just me walking around and picking up garbage,
you know,
that's kind of sweeping shit and stacking drywall.
You know,
I was probably making about seven,
$8 an hour and my dad said to me,
uh,
you're going to have trouble with women.
And I was like,
why?
And he's like,
ah,
I was married to your mom and you were raised by your mom and there's going to
be issues here.
And he shed a,
I'm going to find your shrink and I'll pay for half.
And you pay for half.
Now.
It is insane.
When you make $8 an hour and you're sitting down with someone who gets $100 an
hour for 50 minutes,
it's the most insane thing in the world.
It was literally like five hours of work for me to sit down with this woman in
Beverly Hills and discuss my problems when I was 20.
And what,
what kind of problems that you have that were so unusual that you had to sit
down with a shrink?
My Dad who comes from that kind of world basically said,
you need to sit down with a woman and you need to establish a relationship with
a woman.
That's a good relationship,
basically saying it's not so much the information that you're going to get from
her,
but it's the relationship that you're going to have with her.
So the fact that she's the position of authority and that she's intelligent and
she's rational,
and then you have to see her and you're sort of raise your bar on women because
of that.
Yeah.
Not so much,
um,
raising the bar,
but just like you have never had a positive,
consistent relationship with something that has a vagina.
Uh,
and I,
you need to have that.
Yeah.
So he,
he basically saw trouble in your future?
He did and he,
he knew that,
well,
I didn't have that with my mom and I didn't really have that with my grandma and
I wasn't really having that with anybody around me.
And that this needed to be established.
That's some deep insight by your dad.
Yeah,
I,
it was kind of interest.
I mean,
it is kind of his bag,
you know,
it's kind of his thing,
but it was,
and you know,
it's one of these things where it's like a Multivitamin,
you know,
he's to help people like therapies,
like a multivitamin.
They're like,
does it work?
Does it not work?
I go the field different.
I go,
I don't know.
When you take a Multivitamin,
do you feel different or are you just being active in your health,
into your participating in your health?
Do you know what I'm saying?
Yes.
And you know,
obviously when you take a quite Lou,
do you feel different?
But when you take a Multivitamin,
I don't know if you feel different.
It's part of,
but you should take that multivitamin.
That's what I'm saying,
be active in it.
I always thought,
you know,
half of therapy is you physically getting up and going right to therapy and
participating in that aspect of your life.
So the,
the therapy wasn't like,
it's not something like,
Holy Shit Dude,
you need fucking therapy.
It was more like,
you know,
it's good to take a vitamin.
Yeah.
It's like if your dad was into holistic health and he said,
here's poor kid,
here are some herbs.
Tape bonkers drives me crazy.
The idea that some douche bag who's got a,
an ancient book on leaves knows more than some fucking dude who has spent his
entire life studying diseases.
Yeah.
They have like some really good modern cures,
but no shit had over here wants to give you some holistic cure then may or may
not work.
Well,
here's the whole thing about the holistic stuff for me and it's sort of the,
you know,
the wisdom of the Orient and all that kind of bullshit.
To me it's like this.
If you don't have a real problem then it'll cure whatever your non real problem
is.
If your real problem is just some sort of fatigue that's based on depression or
d or based on something that's going on emotionally in your life,
basically it's living in your head but you say,
oh my joints take and I have trouble getting out of bed and I give you a magic
pill that has a little bit of whisker of the cat and it then that will work on
you.
Now if you got a real problem,
I do a podcast with a guy named Brian.
Brian has a tumor on his brain stem and he's got a real problem that's a
different problem and he takes medication that stops the growth of that.
If that tumor it experimental at the time,
but if that tumor grows then he's dead within six months and he started years
old.
So when you have a tumor on the base of your spine or the top of your spine and
the base,
your brain,
that's an opera ball whisker of the cat and the fucking hair,
the newt
is not going to fucking heel that shit
for you rhino horn for right,
right.
No,
that doesn't work.
If you have a real problem,
that's the best combination.
Like the best comparison rather is Rhino Horn versus Cialis.
Right?
One of them,
you know,
only works in your mind and you're like,
Whoa,
I feel more viral.
And the other one gives you a steel rod and your pants for a solid day.
Right?
You have a choice whether you want to go with Voodoo or that little blue thing.
While the Rhino Horn should be a strap on Rhino Horn,
you should get the whole horn.
Forget about grinding it up and do a fucking powder and putting in your teach.
Give me the whole fucking horn.
I'll put,
uh,
I'll put a,
you know,
Bob bicycle inner tube around it.
Wrapper once around the Pauls and nail over the fucking horn.
Could you imagine how horrible it
would be if men had hard on all the time,
like a horn.
It wasn't a biological process that you had to like engage in your head.
All factors have to be right and anything that's wrong,
fear,
boner shuts down,
drunk.
The boner shuts down,
all these things happen.
Your bonus shuts down.
The complex biological process.
That is the erection.
If we just had a rhino horn and we could just fuck all the time,
what a wreck it would be on earth.
Everyone would have callous dicks.
We'd have like caked calluses all around the outsides of our dicks.
All these places instead of Manny petty places.
The places that would remove the cows is so you could enjoy pleasure with you.
Again,
I'm going to step up your apocalyptic boner future nightmare scenario.
I'm going to fucking turn this one up to 11 then imagine if there were boner
poachers
and they're like,
Hey,
some guy and uh,
Japan wants to make some soup at a Rogan's cock cause he thinks it's going to
make his cock harder.
Wow.
Rogan's at Veeroll guy sit into the MMA.
So the next thing you know,
you've got to look,
you're looking over your shoulder because there's some dude and you don't know
if he's a game warden or she's on your side or their side,
but every time the sun goes down,
you've got to worry about the cock poachers.
Could you imagine there is no way to grow your Dick,
but could you imagine if the only way to grow your dig would be sucking dicks?
You'd have to run around and suck has many dicks as possible to get your Dick
Bigger.
But it did work.
So girl,
when you know you pull your pants up,
she'd look at your deck and she would know for a fact,
wow,
that's a great deck.
But this guy most likely sucked a lot of Cox to get that Dick so big.
Right?
Well then you'd have to explain that that's just a sort of born this way.
God's gift.
Your Dad and Grandpa have huge Cox.
They never suck.
Cock.
Maybe you wouldn't,
you wouldn't want to protest that much.
You don't have to lie about it a little bit.
I don't know.
Body builders and steroids.
I don't know if the chick would assume that,
but it would be an interesting thing to find out a survey of straight guys,
which is if you could grow your cock by sucking cock,
would you be in and down for that?
It would be like,
how much does it grow too?
Oh yeah.
There'd be like,
you suck.
Dick grew an inch.
Holy Shit.
There'd be a long negotiation about swallowing,
about length,
about are we metric or standard.
Here we go in millimeters.
We going by the inch.
How do we do it?
I always say this and it was,
everyone talks about you know your Dick,
your Dick size,
you measure the Dick had he measured the Dick.
I say this,
it should be standardized.
You mentioned your cock this way.
You,
you heard it on Joe Rogan's show it once and for all.
Okay.
The official way to do it,
use a cloth measuring tape,
center of the anus,
watts.
Hear me out.
Center of the anus once around the balls to just pass the tip.
Just pass the test that that's official way.
I measure my cock and I think it should be a standard that's um,
it's very generous of you.
That's your way.
You mess your car.
I've heard these supposed to measure from the bottom and I think that's
ridiculous.
Nobody knows central venous,
don't cheat it back.
Go Center once around the balls.
Just pass the tip.
Let me ask you another thing,
Joe Cocker related.
Okay.
Tell me if you'd be down with this.
I,
I've,
I've given this a lot,
a lot of thought,
a lot more thought than,
than,
than I'm really comfortable admitting.
But I had this idea where we do a water displacement test on every guy over 18
your hard cock into a graduated cylinder filled to the top with water through
just a very thin sheet of like stainless steel,
lower you down and we literally see how much water's displaced by your two
messant cock.
Hmm.
Okay.
Now this factors in girth and length and everything else.
This is so water should be a volume thing.
This is water displacement.
Okay.
Once we do that,
we do it for every male in America over the age of 18.
You then are issued a windbreaker that windbreaker has your ranking on it,
not how much water you displaced,
not how big your caucus but out of,
Oh let's say there's 100 million males that are over the age of 18 and the
United States,
what place you come in.
Number one,
that'd be a pretty fucking good windbreaker to have.
You'd also,
anybody was in the top 10 would be making the fucking rounds on the late night
shows and each year,
you know there's two,
three,
5 million guys turning 18 it all has to be recalibrated every year.
I mean you may see getting bigger if you saw a graph of how big dicks used to be
in the 20s and 2000 well it to,
you know,
just if,
if,
if people are getting bigger,
I'm sure.
Proportionately we are.
So the point is this,
you may be number one,
but there's always some guy turning 18 I mean there's a thousand guys just
turned 18 the time I said that.
And they're getting tested and there's a big reveal and for one month
everybody's got aware that windbreaker,
wherever they are.
And you know,
look,
if you're going to wear that thing for a month,
if you're,
that's the rule,
2 million,
999 billion and someone's,
it's starting at 100 million.
I mean,
you can be sure somebody is going to be last.
Well,
there's three,
150 million,
300 million people in the country,
so 150 million plus minus,
but then you've got to go 18 year old right after that,
but let's just call it 100 million people.
And for my money,
the number one dude is going to do all the late night shows.
And the last dude,
he's going to make the rounds to
one guy that has the biggest cock in the world.
Apparently he went to the Tsa,
uh,
like he was wearing sweatpants and they accused him of trying to smuggle
something.
The guy's got a giant hog.
Yeah.
Apparently it was like all over these news reports.
I white guy too.
Pasty looking white guy.
Yeah.
I think his name is Jonah Falcon or something like that.
That's,
that's what I heard.
I thought,
I think I saw a documentary right.
Do you remember in the porn days?
And it's not saying that John Holmes doesn't have a big Dick.
He definitely has a big Dick.
But you remember when we were kids,
we'd watch porn.
If you saw John Holmes,
you'd be like,
Holy Shit,
that's a big Dick.
Show it on a falcon.
So sad frist by TSA by the way.
Don't believe it.
Ask me who the vice president is.
I'm like,
AH,
state.
Ah Fuck Man.
I didn't know it's going to be a history quiz,
but big Cox,
I'm fucking your man.
John Holmes used to have a giant Dick.
But now that's like pretty standard.
Like there's a lot of those guys with big giant Dicks,
especially the black ones.
I don't,
well I got a theory about big giant black dicks.
Thank God.
Tails nicely into my windbreaker right there.
I got a theory about that.
Um,
and it,
and it is the following.
First off,
how dare you be.
Smirch a good name of Johnny Wad home.
Cause he did have a big Dick still big by today's big Dick Standard.
No doubt.
But,
uh,
as far as black guys having big dicks in porn,
I think that's a form of porn racism.
Hmm.
And I'll tell you why.
I think if you show up onto a porn set is a black guy with a medium sized cock
fair to Midland.
You know,
man,
I got six and a half inches here.
They send you a packet.
They're like,
we don't need black guys with small Cox.
We only need black guys with big Cox.
We can take a white guy with a medium cock,
but we can't take a black guy.
Well,
why bother getting fucked by a black guy if the guy has got a medium cock?
You see what I'm saying?
I think they're discriminated against.
So I think we think the only huge cock we've seen is in porn.
It's on black guys.
They won't let average size cocked black men in.
And I dream of a future where my children can watch pornography and see black
guys with medium sized Cox,
you know,
balls deep in a junky coked up blondes here.
Here.
Yeah.
That's,
that's offensive future for,
yeah.
I remember,
um,
you were talking about Ricky Rachman earlier.
Do you remember the con Wayne Steckler show?
That was a great show,
right?
Yeah.
I love John Wayne Stack,
right?
Yeah.
And,
uh,
didn't Ricky Rachman Punch Steckler stuck in the old days?
Oh,
I think he did to stack used to like mock a show.
They would make fun of a show.
I think I did.
Yes.
He had like the triple r Ricky Rachman radio or something like that.
And there was a lot of that back in the day,
like way back in the day when a Kimball was,
when we're doing mornings,
not me and him,
but on Kevin and being,
and he was making fun of somebody,
uh,
this guy,
this guy came into the studio and just started choking him.
Whoa.
I could literally just
tried to throttle him for no reason.
Just he heard him on the air.
Like,
you know,
the thing about radio is it was real time and it was back in the day.
And I've,
I'd had situations where I've said,
you know,
David,
our cats nuts,
he's insane.
I think he's,
he should be institutionalized and shit like that.
And then like walked out of the studio during a commercial break and David
Arquette is standing there going,
I was driving home from the Lakers game on the 10 freeway.
I was listening to love line.
I heard you call me and saying,
ah.
Then when doctor drew said,
aren't you worried he's going to come over here and punch you?
Uh,
you laughed and said he's too nuts.
He doesn't,
he couldn't find this place and literally told us driver to pull over,
get off the freeway and drove right to us.
It was literally standing there.
Was He mad?
Was He laughing?
He was both,
which I've had a few times.
It's just an insane thing.
It's like you pick a random celebrity,
talk about how nutty you think they are and then 10 minutes later opened that
door and they're standing there.
Yeah.
Worried that I run into Stephen Dorff and I have to explain that I was only
joking about his fucking commercial.
Those.
Yeah,
those are Dorky commercials.
But you know,
the Dorky man or if they weren't your commercials you'd be mocking them to cut
the shit.
I,
I liked him and Blake,
who's awesome,
I've had a lesson,
you know the idea that first off,
I don't know how you are,
but people send me shit all the time.
They're like,
oh,
checkout,
uh,
Andy kindler talking all kinds of shit about your calling you Hitler and this,
that and the other.
Like,
here's a,
here's a link,
you know,
listen to it.
And I just go,
why do I need to go to a link where someone is talking shit about me?
Like I'm not interested in that.
I most people have a morbid curiosity about it.
I'm sure that there are plenty of people that call me an asshole or who think
I'm an asshole or both.
Like I don't,
I'm not interested in stopping them from doing it or,
or curing them of that,
of that problem.
I don't know how you feel like I don't,
I don't seek anything about myself because I know with a ratio of 10 positive
things to one shitty thing and if the one shitty thing is going to fuck your day
up,
don't bother.
You know,
doing,
putting your name and the Google search and seeing what's coming up.
But I assume people are saying shitty things about me all the time.
Well,
some most certainly world will,
especially if you're out in the public eye and it's definitely a good idea.
I think I agree with you 100% don't go searching negative shit about yourself.
It's just,
it's not fun.
It's not,
but David Arquette was in his car,
right?
So he just heard you.
It's kind of funny.
When he did find is funny.
Yeah,
no he was,
it was perfect because we,
we were in Culver city and you have to sort of know the lay of the land out
here.
We were in Culver city.
He had gone to a Lakers game,
I guess it's a staple center.
He was driving back to where Haman,
Courtney Cox live in Malibu.
He had a town car.
Um,
the Lakers game ended it,
you know,
10 o'clock and love lines started at 10 o'clock and he was in his town car at 10
20 driving past.
I mean,
Culver City was a block away from the 10 freeway and he's drunk.
He's listening to love line and he's telling us,
driver,
get off here,
turn off right now.
Turn off right now and turn left and I'll be at the studio.
And there he was.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
So how did you guys end it?
Did it get weird?
No.
So he laughed at it.
At some point in time there was laughter.
Yes.
That's good.
It did not end in a violent or got to know it comes off like a fucking nut.
That's part of his shtick.
Right?
Isn't that a guy who,
you know,
like half of his thing is talking about how fucking crazy he's life is and he
knows he comes off kind of crazy.
I don't get,
I mean,
I've had this happen a few times where I've like said,
well,
this person's nuts.
And then it's like,
Ooh,
they're pissed off.
You called him nuts and it's like it's Marilyn Manson.
Like how do you think they're perceived?
You know what I mean?
Andy Dick got mad at me for talking about how crazy he was on the set of news
radio.
You know,
he's heavy.
Your your debts you like,
that's what the whole thing that you've put out there,
you put out the,
you're crazy,
right?
Hilarious guy.
But he's clearly nuts and not only that,
but there's,
you know,
files and files and files and you know,
whatever municipality police department there is of you doing things that were
clearly a behavior that would not be considered saying behavior.
Right.
We have a rich history of being nuts.
Yeah.
Why not just own it,
own it.
But I think he's one of those guys,
it's like constantly and a rebirthing process constantly.
Like this is it.
Every time I run into him it's like a,
that's it.
I'm sober,
I'm done now I'm done.
I'm done.
The last time I ran into him,
he was sober and
he said he couldn't promise you would stay sober.
Right.
Wow.
You should never be able to say that because if you can't convince yourself,
right,
it's never going to happen.
It's uh,
it's too bad too,
because I always think of him as a very talented dude who just has so many inner
whatever's going on that he was never fully able to realize that talent because
of all the other extraneous,
external sort of things that are going on inside of him.
On the other hand,
you kind of go,
well,
that is who he is.
I mean,
that is why we know of him,
but you wonder and you think,
you know,
what does the future hold?
You know what all that stuff is.
It's,
it's like,
it's like a chick.
It's like,
it's great being drunk and crazy and stupid and hot and 25 but at a certain
point you're going to turn 50 what is that like at that point?
Yeah.
Well,
I think Andy was brilliant on news radio.
One of the reasons why is because he was more reigned in,
you know,
it was his first big Gig is NBC.
He couldn't get,
get too nutty.
They were riding for him.
They're brilliant writers.
They knew how to craft something for him,
but he's,
yeah,
I agree.
He's a very talented guy.
But one of the reasons why he's so funny is most likely in response to those
demons,
like there's sure there's,
there's a,
you know,
there's a yin and a Yang to everything and there there's something that makes
him that way and whatever it is,
he doesn't always have a good grip on it.
No,
but it'd be,
it'd be nice cause he's a nice guy and he's a talented guy.
Yes.
He's definitely a nice guy.
Talented guy.
He's just fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Okay.
What are you going to do?
We live in a crazy place.
Last time I spoke to you,
you were thinking about getting out of here.
We were talking about Seattle.
Yeah.
You were saying it's just too rainy cause you like cars.
If you given any thought to escaping from La,
I've,
uh,
you know,
it's funny,
I travel so much.
I almost feel like I don't live here anyway.
Um,
it's tough because I'm so ensconced in this
podcasting world and production world and working on all these various projects,
independent films and working on Paul Newman racing documentary and all that
kind of stuff and like go out and race my cars and all that kind of stuff and it
just seems almost impossible to do somewhere else.
But then you go to these other places and you see how people interact and you
think,
God,
we don't have that in la at all.
We have a little bit of a in La,
but la inexorably is framed by show.
Business does.
It's just that's what it is.
And there's so many people that even if they don't have a job in show business
at one point in time had show biz aspirations and you and I are bolt in show Biz
so I'm not knocking people that are doing what we do.
But I'm saying is that the majority of people who want to do it,
a lot of times they do it from a deficit.
They do it because they need attention,
they need validation,
they need something and it could matter.
I mean,
that's where I came from for sure,
but it manifested itself in a good way.
It manifested itself in a career and a life and a,
an understanding of myself by by working and creating things.
Right,
but did you feel you needed validation?
I'm sure it did.
I mean,
sure.
I'm sure that's why I got into martial arts.
I'm sure that's why I got into comedy and it will also,
it was an alternative career path for me because that's the only way I was ever
going to have a career.
There's no way I was going to have a normal career.
I was just way too add and way too crazy to be sitting in some sort of a fucking
cubicle,
having some sort of a job in an office.
It was like I would literally feel like a rat in a cage.
I would go crazy.
It's,
I would never be able to pull it off,
so I knew it was going to have to be something alternative,
something outside the norm.
I was just raised to nuts and I did martial art.
Well I did was from age 15 to 21 was competing martial arts tournaments.
So my reality was so fucked and compared to a regular person,
it's like this.
The assimilation had never taken hold,
so I was,
I was in big trouble if I didn't find something like standup comedy,
but I think a lot of the people that come here,
they come here with something like that.
Like there's some,
some reason why they've chosen this,
but a lot of them are trying to define themselves through their success and
they're trying to be somebody they're trying to like and to be around.
A lot of people like that.
It's fucking exhausting.
Some of them are great.
I all,
my friends live here.
That's the thing that keeps me here.
Guys like Joey Diaz and Eddie Bravo and all these pals that I've had for
decades,
they're all here.
So it would make it less,
less enjoyable if I live somewhere else.
Well,
you know what I was saying,
when you go and you travel somewhere and you go into a restaurant,
the waiter or the waitress,
the bartender,
that's what they do for a living.
And,
and that's,
and they've made their peace with that and maybe they're even proud of it and
maybe they found some skill in it and that's what they do.
Um,
here,
the waiter,
the waitress,
the bartender,
that's not what they want to do.
This is only what they're doing temporarily until they can get some gig on a
reality show or whatever it is.
And obviously it's,
their work suffers because you have a lot of people that are passing through.
You know,
I feel like,
like,
I feel like
La is one of the trashiest towns in the world because people are certainly in
the United States.
Hollywood physically is a very trashy town.
Trashy in what way?
On the ground.
I mean,
and I mean literally.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of graffiti,
a lot of weeds growing everywhere.
Just a lot of just kind of garbage.
Like when you go to Phoenix,
it doesn't look like that,
you know,
you got to,
Seattle doesn't look like that.
Why is that?
Well to me,
La is a bunch of people who are treating their city like you treat a rental car,
you know,
you treat your car one way,
that's your car,
the rental car,
and listen,
do you want a light up a cigarette or eat some fast food or and was spilling a
slurpee or something that's like so be it.
You know,
that's kind of how they feel.
And it's funny,
it's interesting.
La is one of the only towns.
Like if you go to Chicago and you go,
hey man,
this town's a piece of shit.
People will go like,
fuck you.
First off,
get the fuck outta here.
And secondly,
we're gonna throw down and are you kidding?
The bars and nightlife,
the river,
the skyline.
Fuck the bears have cubs Wrigley.
Fuck you.
You got to La and go.
La is a piece of shit.
You got a lot of people are going.
Yeah,
I know.
Sorry.
This is awesome.
What are you going to do?
There's too many people here.
That's another reason.
Another reason why it's too hectic.
It's just the numbers are too crazy.
New York is not that fun either in a lot of ways.
Uh,
when it,
last time I went to New York and went through security and the woman at Tsa was
so hostile and I know in a way that you very rarely see in la or anywhere else
and be like,
this is just a person that deals with too many human beings.
Yes.
I didn't say anything to you that's rude.
Like why?
Why?
No,
I know.
Did you ever think Joe as a kid,
you know,
as a kid you thought about being an adult and he thought,
well,
once I'm an adult,
I'm going to be,
I'm going to be a man and I'm going to be treated a certain way and you know,
kids,
I'll have to listen to me.
I'll be someone's dad,
I'll be the boss.
You know,
I'll be,
I'm not saying I'm going to be Donald Trump.
What I'm saying is you'll be adult,
you'll be a man.
Did you ever think that people were going to do a super sing song,
a condescending thing to you as an adult male going,
sir,
take off.
Take all the change out of your pockets.
Completely empty the pockets.
That means chapstick.
That means change keys,
pocket knives,
anything.
Combs,
wallet.
Sir,
is your belt on sir,
sir,
take your belt off.
But sir,
like did you ever think you're going to have semi retarded 28 year old fucking
GDS talk to you in a real condescending sing song he voice when you became a man
and an adult.
I can't believe it.
Every time it happens,
it's so annoying and so stupid.
And I understand that some people have never flown before and they need to be
told all these things.
You should be able to wear like a sticker with a star on it,
right?
I've been here before.
Don't talk to me dummy.
Oh Sir.
You flown before he comes to Corolla.
Put this on your shirt that they're not allowed to talk to you.
Okay.
That's not a fucking flight.
I was on a southwest flight yesterday.
This is a nonsmoking flight.
It is 100%.
Non Smoking is prohibited to smoke on this flight.
Uh,
no smoking in the lavatory will not be tolerated.
Tampering with disabling or destroying the lavatory,
smoked it tastes like,
Hey,
can we get it?
No Smoking.
But it's not her fault though.
They have that at 28 fucking times.
I turned to the person next to me and I said,
we have covered 14 versions of no smoking on this flight.
By the way,
you can say no smoking on this flight.
And that to me doesn't mean,
well you didn't say I couldn't smoke in the bathroom.
That means no smoking.
We understand it's 2000 fucking 14
or even just say including in the bathroom and you're done.
Yeah.
Say No smoking on this airplane.
How about that?
But anyway,
it's funny,
I turned to the guy next to me and I said,
this bitch did five laps on smoking,
but when it came to the oxygen part on the mask,
we only did one lap on that.
So it's like the no smoking,
no shit,
Sherlock thing.
I got fucking 10 minutes a sing song.
He bullshit on that.
The part where there could be an actual emergency and I needed to breathe out of
this thing.
She blew right past that part.
And I thought,
where's your priorities?
Well,
those people,
again,
they're meet too many fucking people.
Yes.
It's just too much going on.
They don't,
they don't value that interaction.
It's not a special interaction.
Right.
You're saying it for the 500000th time.
The lady in New York,
I gave her a,
I was with my family and I gave her my id,
my wife's Id,
and we hired daughter's with us.
We gave their tickets.
So I gave her like four tickets and it was a or five tickets and,
and uh,
two,
uh,
two licenses.
And so she looks at,
she'll,
I don't know who's who,
I don't know what goes where.
Right.
And I said,
Whoa,
whoa.
I go,
why are you being hostile?
She goes,
this isn't hostile.
If you want to see hostile show,
you hostile.
You do.
I go,
I would love to see hostile.
Show me hostile.
And then she just,
your Jewish accent is horrible by the way.
I'm just trying to be diplomatic.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I know.
And the hostile thing,
I mean,
I was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
Talk like are you,
what are you doing?
Is this because you're like a Badass or is it because you're at a position of
power?
Like why the fuck do you think you can say that's on hostile?
If you want to see a hostile,
like what makes you think you're not going to get brained right now?
I like are you,
are you fucking crazy?
Like you're talking shitty.
Do a person for no reasons saying I'll show you hostile.
So
it needs to be these folks,
whether it's the TSA or or LAPD or whoever.
These folks need to be.
Who the fuck they work for?
They work for us.
Someone needs to tell them they work for us.
You're not working for them.
They work for the TSA and the TSA is the government and the government thinks
it's separate from us.
Right.
I should point out too that most of the time that never happens.
Most of the time I go there,
how you doing?
Good morning.
How you doing today?
Everything's good.
How you doing?
And everything's fine.
99.999999% but New York is the place where I've found more hostility dealing
with those people that sell it.
A La is probably second and then ended up pad.
When you travel through Oklahoma,
you get high.
You doing how y'all doing great to have a safe flight.
Yeah,
it's a totally different vibe.
They just seem disinterested in la but they don't seem hostile.
I've never encountered hostility in la,
but no,
I,
I know it's,
it's,
it's aloof,
inserted,
distant and it's this thing where they look at your,
you have an exchange with another human being and they don't punctuate it with
an ending remarks.
So you hand them your Id,
you hand them the boarding pass,
they look at the thing,
they look at you,
they make their led Zepplin band member mark on the fucking thing,
which I'm sure means nothing to anybody to have a highlighter.
And they make their weird mark on there and then they looked down again and then
they hand it to you and then you walk away.
But they don't say enjoy your flight.
You got to Oklahoma.
They say enjoy your flight
and now let you don't even know what they wrote in your ticket.
Like this might be bad to check his underwear.
I don't think they know what they wrote on the ticket.
It writing their name down right there.
Sign Fifth member led Zepplin and if the guy gets through and he's got a fake
id,
maybe they get in trouble like look at his fucking id.
How did you not notice this fake id?
It's got your signature on the,
on the ticket.
Well it is your mark your little suit or whatever it is.
You know,
they're very official with people like sir,
here,
please put your things in the Bin,
take your keys out of your wallet.
They stick with official but sometimes they'll break.
And in La they broke pattern.
They were talking about a basketball game and these three guys,
the guy who was working the,
uh,
the x ray machine and then the two guards,
one of them that's in front of,
uh,
the,
the people thing where the people x ray go through.
And then the other one was on the other side watching the rollers and they're
all going back and forth by all Colby,
why blah,
blah,
and this and that.
And he ain't got no free throw shot.
He ain't got no three.
Well you going to deal with this,
right?
And then back to Sarah,
take your key phones out.
He be like,
wait a minute,
what are you talking about Kim?
My keys out of my pocket.
Like you guys aren't professional.
This isn't you.
I just saw that the veil has been removed.
You guys are regular people.
I had to fart
where I,
the guy and I always drives me nuts.
I don't like when they say for me,
like I don't mind when they go,
could you fasten your seat belt sir?
Or could you,
you know,
take your keys out of,
uh,
out of your pocket,
put it in the tray.
But I don't like when they go for me.
And she bought for me.
I had a guy,
when I was traveling through Burbank,
he needed to take the wand to me.
So he said,
uh,
could you go ahead and turn around for me,
sir?
And I started to turn around and he went real quick and I was like,
first off,
real quick,
like I'm,
I'm halfway into turning around.
So you have about another 0.7 seconds before I arrive at turned around number
one.
Number two,
if I did it real quick,
you probably pepper spray me.
Like he said,
could you go ahead and turn around for me real quick sir?
And I just fucking flew around throwing a crescent kick or something like he'd
fucking tackle me.
So I don't want to do it real quick.
No Bueno mean that though.
The,
that they're making an extra talk.
Well,
yeah,
real quick always means like,
it ain't going to be a big deal to you.
I always see it as like,
yeah,
so it won't take much of your time.
Mr Corolla.
He turn around real quick.
No,
you know,
you know what?
I've Real,
you know what I realized?
I realized a long time ago that cops and security guards do fill our talk and
they do fill or talk so that you won't talk to them.
So if a,
if a cop pulls you over and goes,
uh,
license and ID plays a license and registration please and then just sits there,
you'll start going,
hey man,
what,
what I do or why I was just keeping up the flow of traffic or road.
But instead they always come up and they go,
sure,
when I'm going to need you to do for me right now,
let's go ahead and get your license and registration out for me.
Okay,
right now.
And meanwhile they're doing this kind of pattern.
That doesn't mean anything when I'm going to need you to do for me right now is
to go ahead and get your license.
But that doesn't mean anything other than licensing registration.
They keep a nice sort of white noise buzz,
I should call it blue noise noise that cops make that stop you from going,
what?
What I,
Hey,
I was just pulling out of my dry like they don't want to hear that bullshit so
they just keep that low grade talk going because it's only the cops that do the
for me right now and a lot of preamble into when I'm going to have to ask you to
do for me right now is to go ahead and get your license and okay.
Right now,
like do you ever speak that way to anybody?
I mean if I wanted you to pass me the salt,
what I would I go,
Joe,
what I'm going to have to go ahead and do is ask you to pass me the salt.
Okay.
Right now.
Or when I just say pass me the salt.
I like,
I can't hang out with Adam anymore.
This is too many words.
Yeah.
I'm convinced they talk.
So you don't go,
what?
Why am I turning around?
Well,
what's this mean?
Why didn't do anything?
Yeah.
Most likely.
I mean d people.
I'm very sympathetic to cops first of all because I know a lot of good cops.
I know a lot of cops that I like guys from martial arts and right.
And I also know that you got to cut people a certain amount of slack when all
day,
every day they're dealing with people that are lying to them.
Right.
Dealing with Douchebag,
he's dealing with violent people,
dealing with people,
committing crimes.
I mean they have cops have like one of the worst fucking focus groups ever to
pick from.
Like if you ask a cop like what's a human being like,
oh,
let me tell you what I experienced at my job.
You know,
and ask someone who's a massage therapist,
what's a human being like?
Oh they seem pleasant.
You know,
no hums or tense.
I know.
Listen,
my sister worked at a hair salon in silver like in the 80s on Hyperion
boulevard.
It's like the gay section of Los Angeles.
I said to her many years ago,
I said,
what percentage of guys you think are gay?
And she's like 80% of locking eyes everywhere.
Gay.
She wasn't great at math,
but in her world it was 115% were gay.
So I think she knocked off like 35% rounded down to 80 well that's her world.
Yeah.
And her world,
everyone is gay.
That's a great analogy.
And it's that with cops,
like what percentage of people are assholes?
90% you know,
cause that's who they're dealing with versus massage therapist.
But I always had this feeling,
I know he's always said that,
you know,
cops,
suicides are always really very high,
very high stress.
But you know,
here's,
here's my theory.
It's kind of my black cock and porn theory.
I,
I have a feeling that if I walked around and had a gun on me at all times,
I would have killed myself 15 times by now.
Really?
Yeah.
I just feel like if you put a gun on a guy's hip,
most guys,
guys that you know have that feeling of your girlfriend dumped,
you know,
literally you walked into your apartment and saw your best buddy balls deep in
your girlfriend and then you walked out back to the car and just fucking sat
there with that thousand yard stare and he realized there was a gun on your
fucking hip.
A lot of guys would just put it in her mouth.
A lot of good to go back there and shoot the both the both of them and then put
the gun in your mouth.
I'm just saying the modality for killing yourself,
being strapped onto your hip 24 seven is going to put the likelihood of you
killing yourself.
I mean what if he just said,
hey,
here's where the guy does,
oh,
he stands next to the edge of really tall bridges.
Those guys would have a much higher likelihood of killing themselves too because
every fucking time they heard a piece of bad news,
a certain percentage of them would step off it.
Right?
A certain percentage.
I think a certain percentage of cops suicide,
you know,
everyone talks,
oh,
it's stressful job and all what they seen,
depression,
blah,
blah.
A lot of it is having a suicide machine strapped to your hip all the fucking
time.
I've never thought of it that way.
It's got to up the ante a little bit.
Right.
Certainly it's the trigger out.
Literally it's right here on your hip by law,
even when you're on your days off,
that shit's gotta be there.
Whew.
Yeah.
I guess I,
you know,
I've never thought about killing myself,
so I'm,
I,
I kind of,
um,
when I say I relate,
I don't,
you know,
I,
I've always been of the idea that life will eventually get better as we talked
about before.
And I've never thought,
but I've never had like a mental,
a depression issue that I have friends who clearly have,
I have friends that had real deep,
unquestionable chemical problems and they,
they cured it through antidepressants,
but I've never had that.
So I don't understand that,
that thought process,
the,
the kill yourself thought process.
But I've seen it enough to know that I wouldn't want everybody to have a gun
strapped to their hip.
They,
I think you're right.
I think a lot of people would make that fatal mistake.
Initially we were talking earlier about being a dude and being 24 and just,
we'll making really bad snap decisions
would hog go up for sure.
And I sank or you know,
maybe eventually it would mellow out and they,
the old adage of a well armed society is a polite society.
Right.
But there's that expression,
I don't remember who made it,
but it's that when you a,
all you have is a hammer.
Everything looks like a nail.
If there's no diplomatic solution available because you carrying a 44 magnum in
your pocket.
Well that's my feeling with shit.
Like,
you know,
uh,
I mean when I was doing the man show,
one of the riders got ahold of one of those tasers and I was like,
electric taze there's not,
not this,
not this serious cop.
One's a personal size one.
I have been hit by one of those serious cop ones,
but the personal kind of mail order ones,
he taste every fucking person in that building.
I mean,
y'all Fab was it?
When he tased you?
It's uncomfortable,
but it's,
you know,
it's like wow.
Yeah,
that,
that's what it is.
But the point is,
is if you're walking around with pepper spray on your belt,
you weren't going to fucking use that pepper spray at some point.
Yeah.
I mean most people would.
It's almost the having it that makes you use it.
You know what I'm saying?
It's that kind of
kind of thing where that's,
you know,
I liked the idea
of people being able to protect themselves.
I also feel like you walk around with a gun strapped to your hip long enough,
it's coming out at some point.
Whereas you and I don't walk around with a gun,
so we'd probably figure out a way other than that to resolve this issue.
Well,
it certainly takes a deep responsibility.
Like you,
you have to have a deep understanding of the responsibility that you carry and
you carry it around all the time.
This ability to end life like that.
Yeah.
And,
and I it,
everywhere you go
and anybody who's been out shooting,
and I've been out shooting t to feel what a,
what a 44 feels like in your hand and then squeezing off and that just the
recoil and everything,
it's powerful.
Unbelievable.
You couldn't imagine pointing that at somebody and squeezing the trigger.
The people that do that on either side of the badge to people that do that sort
of routinely or cavalierly.
You know the people that do the,
I asked the guy for his wallet and he wouldn't give it to me,
so I shot him.
It's,
it seems insane because if you've actually gone down to a range and just felt
that power and that responsibility and just the,
the,
the recoil,
the kickback and this sort of visceral whatever firing off a few rounds from
that 44 you couldn't imagine pointing it at somebody and squeezing that trigger.
Well,
it's Kinda interesting.
Like I'm,
I am 100% for people being allowed to possess firearms,
but I also am 100% shocked that more firearm deaths and accidents don't happen.
If you think of the idea that all these people around us,
millions of people around us can legally have guns and if they legally have
guns,
like what does the,
how come we're not hearing pop,
pop pow like guns going off left and right.
People are retarded.
Like I'm,
I'm shocked every time I get on the highway and I'm amazed that people can go 70
miles an hour,
a couple of feet away from another thing going 70 miles an hour and they know
just fucking slamming each other left and right back and forth.
Constant maze of accidents.
Yeah,
I know.
I,
I'm,
I think that same way every time I drive.
And I think the same way when I hear that,
you know,
there's a gun,
however many guns are in circulation in the United States,
basically one for every citizen that's out there and we all know about
David Arquette or Andy Dick or any other nut job that's out there.
You take all the people that are having emotional issues are a little bit off
and all the medication that's out there and all the booze that's out there.
And then you mix that with all the guns that are out there.
Why do we not step outside of the studio and hear gunfire going left and right?
Yeah.
It's,
it's kind of amazing you think about it and it's also amazing how many fucking
people there are out there that are going through problems that keep it
together.
There's a lot of people out there,
their life is shit and turmoil and they still manage to get to work every day,
do their fucking job and pull out of the ashes,
right?
We concentrate on the people that just go,
fuck this,
boom.
But how many people think about going,
fuck this and make it and figure it out.
And then 10 years later,
a 10 years ago,
my life was in shambles.
I was ready to kill myself.
Now look at me.
I'm happy.
I'm doing great.
I've got a family,
but,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
Oh God,
I was thrown out of the police academy,
killed myself,
was whatever it is,
whatever it is that allows people to pull through,
I mean,
I'm all for it because I think we're all people.
I know that you can handle driving a car and I know that I can handle driving a
car,
but I also know that some people are going to drive drunk,
fucked up,
go 120 miles an hour,
slam into other people and kill people.
So if that person exists,
should we keep that right from everybody?
No.
I say no.
I say people should be allowed to drive cars until they show that they're a
danger driving a car.
Unfortunately,
there's only one way to do that.
You got to fuck up somebody else's time,
right?
You got to fuck up.
And that's,
that's the real issue.
It's like the amount of actual cars driving in comparison to the amount of fatal
accidents is fucking insanely high.
Insanely high.
I mean,
the odds of you driving around and not having a fatal accident are pretty
fucking Sporty,
right?
They're pretty sporty.
But
when things do go wrong,
people automatically look for the most drastic measure.
Like we got to take guns away from people.
We've got to pull the guns,
we've got a Google car,
everything,
no more,
no more driving your own car.
That's common.
Adam Corolla and I know you're a car nut,
that Google car shit.
Once they get that down,
there's going to be no reason for you to be able to weave in and out of Google
cars and make it to work.
Well,
you know,
we,
I always say we're bizarre society and we should always just work big to small
and we don't like it.
Take Los Angeles were,
you know,
basically last in education.
Our schools are nuts.
It is nuts and our schools are failing our kids.
And then you turn on the news and they say,
new legislation out of Sacramento wanting to ban e-cigarettes and years,
you're like,
uh,
sorry Ethan Hawke.
But the,
the point are a,
so I think an oh Stephen Dorff the point is this,
get those guys confused.
E cigarettes.
Who the fuck cares about e cigarettes?
Now look,
I don't hope that my kids grow up to smoke e-cigarettes,
but I don't give a fuck if there's some 45 year old guy who's trying to get off
the bus and a standing outside of his job smoking a cigarette.
And I walked by and get a little fucking water vapor,
uh,
on my scalp.
I'm fine with that.
Uh,
I,
I would,
I wouldn't give a shit if everyone smoked in east cigarette.
If we could get from 50th in education up into the top 20.
I don't know.
Why were we have,
you know,
the worst traffic congestion on the planet and the worst schools and you know,
in America.
And yet every piece of legislation is surrounded about,
you know,
uh,
fast food workers need to start wearing gloves to handle the food back.
You know,
I don't give a fuck about that.
I don't give a fuck about e cigarettes.
I don't know who does.
I don't know an individual that has ever been harmed by an east cigarette and I
don't know an individual it's ever been harmed by guy works at Taco bell making
this fucking Burrito by hand.
I everything I've eaten in my entire life that's come from a restaurant,
some guy made with his hands,
I'm fucking fine.
What a don't like.
It's the school's being last.
Why that's not an issue.
I don't know.
I don't like both.
I don't like dude's a dirty hands and making my tacos and I don't like shitty
schools.
Right?
But to me,
if you give me a choice and I'm a in Sacramento,
I'm going to focus on the schools and when I get that settled,
then I'm going to focus on the guy guys picking this nose and making money.
But obviously the people that are bringing up this e-cigarette thing,
it's a,
it's coming from someone in the health department and looking for another thing
to do.
I mean,
that's the only thing that makes sense.
It's like some new project to take on.
When you look at the actual effects of the secondhand vapor,
it's nonexistent.
There's nothing,
there's no data,
there's nothing that shows his dangerous,
it snows.
The other problem though is those big fucking cannons that these dudes are
carrying around.
People are carrying around these big giant electric,
like Brian Red Band had one and he was blown it in here and I'm like,
I'm breathing in that stuff.
Like that's not the same.
It's like one of those blue e cigs,
right?
They're all those.
All those things are not created equal.
I think about what
you're breathing in when a guy's got a leaf blower going and your neighbor's
driveway and he's just fucking all the shit that's on the ground.
All the pesticides,
everything,
all the pollen,
all the Dander and all this shit that is vulcanized rubber and Cockroach,
fecal matter.
When that all goes fucking airborne and now you're taking your dog or your kid
for a walk up the street.
What do you think that's like?
Hmm.
And what's it like when you're walking down a busy sidewalk in downtown La and a
big municipal bus goes blowing by at 40 miles an hour and whatever.
Kitten kicked up and coming off of that.
Yup.
E-Cigarette any day.
And the other thing to think about his brake dust,
people don't think about break.
Oh yeah.
Brake dust is real everywhere around you.
Everywhere you go,
when you see traffic,
you have brake dust.
It's in the air.
People are hitting their brakes,
the brakes are disintegrating.
It's all over the wheels.
Whenever you clean your car,
you know this,
you cleaned your wheel and you see all that black powder.
Well that Shit's not just stuck to your wheel.
It's in the air.
And people who live near highways,
they're breathing that stuff in all fucking day.
It's uh,
by the way,
the biggest manufacturer brake pads,
it's called Raybestos.
Oh No,
what a terrible name.
It,
I think they were around before as best as Swiss.
It's bad as it is,
but Raybestos yeah,
they really,
they were,
well I hadn't manufactured around the forest pesto's well,
no,
before asbestos was bad.
Oh,
before it was bad.
And I think Ray Bestus if we've got to look it up on your computer,
but I think it probably had his best though Senate.
I mean because there's a ton of heat generated by the brakes.
That makes sense.
And as it needs to be something that it's going to be heat resistant and not
where,
Ah,
you know,
it's not chunk of rubber.
Yeah,
yeah.
Huh.
That's interesting.
It's interesting too that they haven't figured out anything better for a break.
Then I'm a piston that's slams a pad against a piece of steel that's next to
your wheel.
It gives you friction.
Yeah.
Incredible amounts of friction.
I mean that's,
that's what they figured out for breaks.
I just uh,
got back from a vintage race last weekend and I drove an old Datsun and the
breaks and the old Datsun,
although they don't work nearly as good as the one in the new car,
it's exact same thing.
So Piston,
it's a pad pushes down,
it's eroder squeezes,
it creates friction and that's that.
Um,
now you know,
but the steering wheel and the wheels and the internal combustion engine haven't
changed.
Not much either.
I mean it's all the rear end and the transmission,
it's all a thousand times better in a new car than it is in one of these old
race cars.
But it's still just same old,
same old and the electronic suspensions to the suspensions nowadays with
stability management systems and traction control and all the different
calculations that car's making.
Oh dreidel I was driving,
my wife's to Audi and it applied the break for me.
Why?
Because I was driving like a dick.
So it started slowing you down?
No,
it said you're going to t boned the car that's ahead of you.
Like you're going to go up the ass of the car in front of you.
And I'm like,
I know what I'm doing and here's how I drive,
you know,
and it's like,
well,
according to our data,
you're going to hit this guy.
I just picked up my foot to put it on the brake pedal.
And it popped out of my foot and depressed for me.
Wow.
Thing basically said was,
you know,
I was doing a show at like the Irvine Improv,
all the fucking traffic,
you know,
between here and there.
And you know,
I had to be there at eight o'clock or whatever.
And I was trying to make some time just driving down the Hollywood freeway.
And so I was on it when there was a little opening and then brake lights and
this thing broke for me.
And I'm,
I'm,
because I do a lot of driving.
I'm used to just doing it on my own,
you know.
Did you,
um,
see that controversy about that?
Um,
that a reporter was the named Jeremy K.
Hill?
What the fuck was his name,
who died?
Who,
uh,
was,
he exposed,
um,
a bunch of shit about a general Petraeus and some other generals and he was
like,
just generally like a rabble rouser type reporter.
And,
uh,
he was constantly worried that he was going to get killed,
constantly talking to people that were saying they were going to kill him.
And then one day,
like four o'clock in the morning,
driving down sunset goes like a hundred miles away into a tree with no evidence
that he's tried to slow down or stop.
The engine goes flying from the car.
Explosion like Michael Hastings,
Michael Hastings,
that's his name.
Yeah,
I do remember that story.
Yeah.
You know,
I just kind of went away,
didn't it?
Well,
the thing is,
everything just kind of goes away now because there's so much,
there's so much,
and everyone is broken off.
You know?
I don't know.
I don't know if we could have another Watergate,
you know,
because there's just too many people that are into their shit and there's,
there used to be three news outlets,
you know,
the major three networks,
whatever the evening news,
Walter Cronkite,
whatever.
Now there's just so many outlets,
so much,
so many stories and so much that needs to feed that machine.
You don't do 24 hour news stations,
outlets.
You've got to keep that shit.
You got to keep those plates spinning and our attention span,
it's just not long enough.
Yeah.
There's always any margin airliner thing.
Right,
right
thing and we just don't care.
Yeah,
and and I mean ultimately we're sorta narcissist,
but then secondly,
there's just something new to replace something every day,
all day.
And there's nothing that they just,
nothing could hold our attention.
I mean I was very young,
but I remember Watergate and I remember that was it.
That's all anybody talked about was Watergate,
Watergate,
that,
that that's what happened.
That's what was happening.
I don't know if we're going to have that ability anymore.
I mean timber level,
this is probably the closest thing.
Yeah.
I mean you're going to have to have something on that scale and even then
there's going to be a certain and a fairly large segment of society that's still
getting caught up on honey booboo and doesn't give a shit about the tower and
maintenance.
I didn't even know about it.
And September 11th was also,
you think about the time of 2001 is compared to the time now,
the Internet,
that use of the Internet,
the,
the spread of information.
It wasn't even close to being the same thing and totally not just the sheer
volume of fucking stories that you get every day that you have to sift through.
Interesting non-interesting ridiculous,
baffling animal attacks,
explosions,
poisonings,
oil leaks,
Jesus fucking Christ,
another plane crash,
boom,
boom.
It never ends.
And I don't know,
you know,
I don't know how much of this were geared to or supposed to ingest and digest
like I don't know.
As human beings,
I know we haven't changed biologically that much and the past several hundred
years,
but yet things have changed a lot.
As of years.
We were very,
very,
very similar to the people that live 50,000 years ago.
Right?
Right.
But yet you're holding a device in your hand that has more computing power than
the first Gemini Rocket Launch.
So what are we supposed to do with that,
that information and how are we supposed to process it?
And when does it become detrimental?
Like we're,
are we supposed to be somewhere processing information all the time?
I mean,
I'll give you a,
I was just saying this,
but I found it sort of interesting.
I was doing this,
a vintage car race,
so I was out to dinner after the race with a guy who owns an airline,
not a big one,
like a medium size one.
And I said,
uh,
tease man,
what,
what went on with that seven,
seven,
I'm Malaysian plane.
You know,
like you're,
you own airline,
what do you think?
And he said,
yeah,
I don't know.
And I said,
can you just,
can you dismantle or,
or make those course transponders on the seven,
seven,
seven dysfunctional can you can just flip a switch or have to pull a fuse or
breaker or something like that.
And he said,
it was about seven o'clock.
We were just sitting there and some Mexican food joint,
uh,
outside of the track at Laguna Saca and a northern California.
And he said,
uh,
hold on,
let me,
let me hit my guy.
Now his guy is,
when you run an airline,
you have to have like a chief engineer or something like that.
It basically tells you all the specs on the planes and the INS and outs and how
many hours engines have on them and what tires to get all,
you've got to have a couple of those guys,
right?
So he said,
let me hit my guy.
So he just picked up his phone.
He didn't get up and leave or anything.
He just picked up his phone and he texted this dude,
you know,
and now I didn't think about it to later,
but this was Saturday night at seven 30 at night.
Well,
his dude,
he's probably eating dinner with his family.
Maybe he's fucking his girlfriend,
or maybe he's out to dinner with his wife,
but now his little device starts buzzing and this is a little device.
It's the boss man on his device.
He can't get back to him on Monday.
The boss man just asked him a question and now he's got to find out how you
dismantle a beacon on a seven,
seven,
seven.
Now I don't know if he knows it or he's got to go look it up.
But either way,
if this guy is sitting with his kids or sit with his wife or fucking his
mistress,
he's got to go,
oh shit,
I got to figure this shit out and give this guy an answer now because he's the
boss and he just asked me,
fuck that.
It's Saturday night,
right?
Fuck that.
It's the weekend and I'm with my family.
[inaudible] I got to know,
and this guy probably had a little anxiety and this guy probably thought,
Eh,
I'll get back to him Monday and then thought,
fuck,
I don't want to do that.
I better get back with him now.
He probably wants to know now and this guy probably had to get up and go
somewhere,
hop on a computer,
do something,
figure out that,
whatever.
And then he had to go right,
this guy back on a Saturday night.
Well,
that's where,
that's how we're living now.
And I don't think it's good
data aspect of it.
I agree with you.
That's pretty rare.
I think also the amount of numbers that are coming in,
uh,
I think we're eventually going to adapt.
I think human beings have a thing called Dunbar's number.
Are you aware that you can only keep about 150 relationships?
150 friendships,
150 people you know by name and face.
After that shit starts getting weird and I'm sure you've encountered that.
You,
you meet people and they go,
hey,
it was great when I met you before we had a good time.
Remember?
And you're sure I don't remember you.
There's no room.
You have no room in your hard drive.
Right?
Because we're not really designed to meet a million people over the course of a
life,
which you very well have probably met a million people.
The average person doesn't get to do that in a tribal situation 50,000 years
ago.
We carry those same genetics today.
And I think that is also,
that also applies to dealing with danger and the idea of hearing about news
because news and danger usually affects you.
But when that news and danger is a plane halfway around the world,
it becomes a sort of a weird abstract thing.
And you're getting all these abstract,
never negative things that are happening all the time.
Every fucking point of the globe sends you it's worst news.
Oh,
we found a new serial killer,
only eats babies.
Well,
we found a fucking guy who has been living in the woods and you know,
we found this,
we found that everything that's fucked up,
everything terrible and it all comes into your head and you have to,
at this point in our lives,
you have to filter it.
If you don't feel dread,
you will truly go insane.
Like your biology can't manage it.
You're not designed for it.
It's not a normal thing.
It's not new and we haven't adapted yet.
So you better manage it.
You better like make a conscious decision to manage it or it'll fucking move
your life in the way it wants to.
It will change your thought patterns,
change your perceptions of the world.
And based on an insane number of 7 billion human beings,
unusual events,
7 billion,
which is 7,000 million human beings problems,
right?
That's too many.
You're supposed to deal with 150.
That's why you have this number,
Dunbar's number that's in your fucking head.
One 50.
That's it.
Not 7 billion.
That's fucking crazy.
So that change has been so radical and so quick.
There's no way our biology right now is caught up to it,
but I bet future generations will have some sort of an alteration in their
ability to,
to either absorb massive amounts of information or some sort of a change in the
way we process that information.
Right?
Right.
And,
uh,
we're just like the Guinea pigs and we see how much medication and how much we
can all freak out over what's going on.
And it's,
it's true.
And I,
and I feel the same way.
I just feel inundated and overwhelmed.
And like there's so much coming at me at once.
Concept.
Well,
you have to think about language.
When language burst onto the picture,
when people started communicating with each other and recognizable sounds almost
immediately people started explaining their problems and all,
they started commiserating and started figuring each other out,
and from there,
from that point on,
the world got way more complicated.
It wasn't just do what you feel and and following instincts and make grunts like
we're a tiger is like you're actually communicating.
You're complaining,
you're whining,
you're expressing your,
your fears for the future.
We have to create gods.
You have to create the reason why the lightning comes down.
I mean,
things like exponentially changed.
It wasn't like all the sudden human beings were different.
No,
human beings are the same,
but now all this new information is coming in and as they're developing this
thing called language,
I think we're at a very similar place right now and the changes between us of
today and what we will be a thousand years from now,
we'll probably just as radical as it changes of nonspeaking hominids to speaking
hominids.
Well that's a very interesting and uh,
I grain have always just thought about what are the longterm effects of sort of
having everything at your fingertips constantly.
You know,
I always say when I grew up and I wanted to see the Grinch that stole Christmas,
that came on ABC at eight o'clock on December 13th and you had to wait a,
you could not see it before then.
And by the way,
he couldn't see it after then either.
If you were,
you know,
in the kitchen and the commercial break was over,
you had to fucking sprint,
you're a little jammies with the feet built in and slide across the floor to see
it.
And it was a kind of a foreplay.
And now if my kids want to see the Grinch that stole Christmas,
they can see it in July on Blu Ray.
But I don't think it means shit to them.
Even better.
They can see it on iTunes instantly on the iPad sitting in the living room be a
bit,
yeah,
and it's playing or in the head rest of Mommy says,
right.
Are they happier because of that?
I don't think they are.
If you would've asked me,
would you like to see the Grinch that stole Christmas whenever you wanted and
the head rest of Mommy's car?
I would have said yes,
but I don't think I would have been happier because all it does is speed you up,
changes your expectation level,
and then every once in a blue moon when you don't get to see whatever it is you
want to see exactly the same time,
I mean you then you're pissed off.
Yeah.
And,
and I,
you know,
my kids are probably going to be walking around at age 25 going,
hey man,
I want to see fast and furious one 29 and someone's going to go,
well,
it doesn't come out for four months.
Oh,
that's such bullshit.
Fucking go get it.
Well Gia and put it in my box.
I want to watch it on my phone and they're going in my head.
Well watching my head,
I just want to close my eyes and they go,
it's not done.
Fuck that.
This is such bullshit.
Have you seen this new store that came out today?
The picture that Jamie put up earlier that by 2030 there and I have mind a mind
thought toss talking.
Wow,
mine too.
And that this is something that I've been bringing it up for a while,
that I think that human beings like the interface of sounds like using sounds
and even using language is a temporary thing.
I think that there's gonna come a point in time where you're going to be able to
read like intent.
You're going to be able to,
I might not be able to understand what's going on in your head the same way you,
when you have thoughts in your head,
when you have ideas,
you're not doing it with a language you're not.
You're not expressing your thoughts to yourself with a language.
Very rarely do I say,
well,
it's about time to pull yourself by your bootstraps and get back to work.
I just have a feeling in my head that represents those words and I've had that
exact same thing happened to me during like heavy duty psychedelic experiences.
I've had something relay information to me in the form of intent instead of in
words.
I think that ultimately like in having experienced it in a psychedelic state
like,
uh,
on dimethyltryptamine or on mushrooms,
I think that's probably what you would experience when they figure out this sort
of technology.
Like I'll be able to read your intent and it will be free of language.
Like you're just signals that are going on inside your mind.
You'll be able to
distribute those to other people.
All right,
so you do,
you know,
I have to piss really good.
Go ahead and pass mic.
I'm kidding.
No,
I,
it's,
it's already,
it's already incredibly interesting to me that you can take amputees that are
cut off at the elbow strap on,
uh,
you know,
robotic prosthetic,
whatever,
and their brain is able to tell it,
you know,
to pick up,
uh,
a grape lightly enough not to squash it or pick up a pencil hard enough to hold
it in their hand and which fingers and digits to move just from the brain to a
severed limb and get that thing to function.
I mean,
obviously that's your brain communicating with something without language.
And to me the leap between making your brain communicate with animatronic digits
that are moving around and unscrewing Manet's jars are picking up pencils or
holding your child.
That's not a very big leap to get from moving that hand around using your
thought versus communicating that way.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
I,
I think it's just a matter of time.
Like this thing says 2030 that sounds totally normal to me.
I mean especially when you consider the exponential pace at the things
improving.
I was a at a company in San Francisco for a,
the Scifi show that I did where we put on these head gear and you control a
remote controlled helicopter with your mind,
with your thoughts,
like your intent moves.
This thing I was able to like have it hover in the air for a little bit,
but apparently once you get good at it,
you can actually move it down the hallway and park it someplace.
And I mean it's,
it's fucking bananas.
You're,
you're piloting a really crude remote control vehicle with your thoughts.
Right.
And this is a matter of time before they figure out how you're going to have
fucking robots flying around your house,
fetching new coffee.
You're going to look at your robot,
your little flying fucking helicopter robot coffee maker,
and you're going to say,
go make me some coffee,
stupid and it's going to fly off and make you coffee and come back and give it
to you and you're able to do all this with your mind.
And I've got to say it,
you know,
just do it.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I mean the drones are already stepping up.
It's a lot of it is computers versus batteries.
You know,
it's the batteries that were bricks,
um,
just 10 years ago,
I mean batteries were just huge bricks and now they're the size of corridors and
they're producing the same power because all this stuff needs to be propelled by
something.
You know,
there needs to be
system that powers it up.
And I know,
even though it sounds corny way,
I used to fly remote control airplanes and they had electric ones.
And the problem with the electric ones is the battery was literally a brick and
it's hard to fly a little styrofoam playing with a brick,
the middle of it.
And now most all of them are electric just because of the cell phone technology
and the battery that has been shrunk,
enlightened to the point where it's,
it's nothing anymore.
Yeah,
it's amazing what they can do too with the,
the algorithms that they have and they're in their operating system for power
management.
Like you could take an iPad and you can watch five fucking movies on a flight
and it doesn't run out of juice.
Right?
You're watching a fairly big screen and all these images are being processed.
It's constantly moving around.
You Watch a whole fucking movie and then you look at your battery and it's like
barely budged.
Well,
because
nothing there,
there's,
there are no more moving parts.
I mean,
there used to be conveyor belts and they're powered by rivers with wheels in
them and that took a lot of energy and now everything is digital and there's no
parts,
there's no friction.
There's no,
you know,
you don't realize,
well you probably realize,
but you know whenever you talk about a car and you talked about horsepower,
you go,
how much is it making to the crank and the guy goes 500 horsepower and then you
go,
what's it make into the rear wheels?
And you go,
well let's make it about (430) 420-5430 right?
All right,
that's not bad.
Good.
May we get some synthetic oil and that rear end and get it up to four 31 or
whatever it is.
But you are scrubbing off all of that inertia and all of that torque and power
because it's having to pass through drive shafts and transmissions and
differentials and it's scrubbing it off.
But if all that was digital,
then you'd have 500 horsepower at the crank and 500 it's a rear wheel.
And that's what we're getting now.
That digital,
is that what they get with like Tesla's,
are they like,
is there a,
is there horsepower at the engine?
The same as at the wheel?
Well,
what,
what they're getting and what they're doing now is it's all about torque and
it's instant torque with electric motors.
So they're getting that big,
that's why the Tesla zero to 60 is not much off of,
if not the same as your Porsche.
Now your top speed and your poor shows faster,
but the zero to 60,
it's that kind of golf cart kind of thing.
Again,
a golf cart and the guy hits it,
she'll flying off the back.
Yeah.
I mean,
imagine a real car with four motors on all four wheels so you get the instant
torque immediately.
But secondly,
and I,
I've not studied to Tesla that closely,
but the motor is connected to the wheel.
There's no transmission that it's passing through propeller shaft and
differentials and things that are scrubbing off inertia.
Who you fucked with those at all?
Teslas.
I,
I've drove a,
I just drove one around once and it's there quick.
I mean,
they're super quick.
They're really,
uh,
my friend Aubrey has one and they have a laptop in the middle of it,
like essentially like
it's huge.
And he goes,
uh,
we were going to the gym.
He goes,
he said,
the name of the gym,
navigate to [inaudible] and it just takes you there.
And I'm like,
this is fucking insane.
I get it.
It finds it on Google maps,
gives you the option,
you press a button and this huge navigation screen when you wanted to listen to
music,
he's like,
um,
play the doors.
So all of a sudden it,
Spotify pulls up all these options for the doors break on through to the other
side,
plus plus that one,
boom.
And it starts playing and it gets it all through the actual computer itself on
the,
on the,
on the car,
not even connected to your phone.
It's a completely independent all it uses some sort of unfortunately three g not
four g connection.
Yeah.
It's unbelievable.
Um,
this is going to be a rough transition,
but seeing as how I have to go do my podcast pretty quick on the topic of
podcasts,
you know,
I'm being sued.
Yes.
And uh,
explain that to people because it's one of the dumbest fucking lawsuits I've
ever heard in my life.
But there's people that make a living off of these types of lawsuits right
there.
Yeah.
Called Patent trolls that buy up patents and their lawyers.
And it's Sorta,
I think it's this country at its worse.
I really do.
It's they buy patents and then they shoe companies saying they're using stealing
or unlawfully using their technology.
And sometimes when you're buying technology,
there's a real good argument to that.
Like that technology is a part of this thing that you're selling.
And without that technology,
which is patented,
your technology,
what you're selling would not exist.
Right.
And I get that part and I support innovation and people should be paid for for
intellectual property and creative ideas.
But this is a weird one.
This is,
what is the exact term that,
that they have a patent on the exact cause they have a patent on a playlist.
Yes.
So online,
anything in a serial order.
Right,
right.
Even blogs,
I evidently anything that's comes out on a Monday and then the next one comes
out on a Tuesday or this song is above that song and this song is number three
and that song's number seven.
That's what they claim to have dementia.
No,
first,
so if you have a blog and you enter into the blog,
like a blog entry number one,
you know a Adam goes to do podcasts to talk about this lawsuit.
They could sue you for that.
Like they own a piece of that,
a serialized message that you're putting on a website.
Yeah.
Numbered message that that's correct.
That's insane.
Well,
this insane because if it's true,
then really everything on the Internet's got it.
Go Away.
Everything.
Could you imagine if they bought up everything on the Internet with one sneaky
move,
like one sneaky move,
one pan with the judge says,
look,
the guy's got a point.
He owns a everything in serialized form.
Well,
the price number,
the problem is is I don't think the judge or the jury is going to think they
have a point.
Unfortunately,
in order to make our point that they don't have a point,
it's going to cost one point $5 million.
Holy Shit.
That's what patent litigation costs.
That's what the legal fees are going to be.
That's what,
that's what I've been quoted.
Oh my God,
I've been quoted 1.25 to 1.5 wow.
Yeah,
that's stunning.
I never would have thought it would be that high.
So are they offering hade a lot?
So there's a,
is that what it is?
It's all the lawyers.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
It's all the lawyers and that.
How much work did they have to do here,
Joe?
For me it's like first off,
I spent $50,000 trying to get a change of fucking venue.
These guys are in eastern Texas.
That's where they set up
because eastern Texas is famous for friendly to their types of folk.
Yeah.
To this type of thing.
Patent troll lawsuits.
I don't live in eastern Texas and my business isn't in eastern Texas and they
don't live in eastern Texas either.
That's just where they hung their shingle
and they hung their shingle specifically because this is a place it's
advantageous to do things like this.
Well,
it's what you would do if you were company that bought up other people's
technology and then tried to sue other businesses and make money off of them.
You're going to maximize that,
the possibility of you getting an outcome that's in your favor and you'll do it
on the moon if you have to.
Now,
if these people come to you with some sort of a settlement,
like if they said,
hey,
you know,
you're using our technology,
we would like five bucks a month.
Like anything along those lines,
$3 million.
Whoa.
And this,
because they've,
they've won these before,
the same company.
They got $8 million from apple,
right?
Yeah.
It's,
it's unclear what I'm doing with them and what they're doing with me.
But it's a pretty simple equation,
which is I just said,
look,
all the guys in podcasting need to kind of band together and we need to fight
them and then we need to beat them.
And then once we beat them,
then their beat,
cause they can't go after you or mark Marin or whoever once we beat them.
But if we allow this to just go away,
it's not going to,
if we say,
well let's just put it aside and you know,
fucking ignore them,
then they win.
I mean,
it's a possibility that they could win.
There's no way.
Look,
when you get sued,
you get sued.
You're gonna to respond.
But you know,
let's just say,
we said,
look,
uh,
you guys obviously haven't done the math on our company,
but you know,
it's,
it's a business.
No one wants to spend the time and the 1 million plus dollars to fight this
thing.
You know,
take 350 grand and please go away.
Or 500 grand or a hundred grand,
whatever it is.
Well,
how long before they go to iTunes and they go,
Ooh,
let's see who else is doing okay over here on iTunes and they take a piece of
this doing all right.
Now,
last time we did this with Corolla,
we got 500 k out of him when we chose good for and all we got to do is do the
same thing we did with Corolla.
He knows,
I mean,
we'll let,
we'll let Joe's attorneys coach him up,
but they're going to tell you this,
the most expensive kind of litigation,
it's going to cost over a million dollars.
I mean he can go on the Internet and look that up.
Know,
and beings are behind this.
Do you know the actual human beings?
Uh,
are you aware of the names or faces?
Do you know what they look like?
No,
I don't and I never think that way.
Like I,
I just think the,
I understand that we live in a world that is generally decent and that these
people probably think of themselves as generally decent.
You know,
they probably have kids that love them and a wife that,
uh,
it gives him a blowjob on occasion.
This is what they do for living.
This is their business.
And I think when a guy works at a used RV lot and he's got an Rv on that lot
that's worth $4,000 and some elderly couple comes in there and he gets them for
20 grand,
he doesn't go home and stare in the mirror and go,
wow,
I'm a really bad human being.
He goes,
I'm a fucking great salesman.
And I think that's what these guys do.
I don't even fault them.
And on a personal level,
like they make money from doing this.
I understand it.
Uh,
it's,
no,
it's not even worth trying to make it a personal issue.
I don't feel it's a personal issue.
They saw my podcast,
I'm actually in a bizarre way,
flattered.
They saw my podcast and said,
that guy is really doing well for himself.
I,
let's go get 3 million bucks.
That's insane that that was the first offering.
So it's stunning.
What we're doing is we're getting everyone together and we're going to show him
that the podcast community is a lot stronger than they thought,
that they fucked with the wrong people.
And I don't mean me,
I mean everybody and that whether you're a Joe Rogan fan or Adam Carolla fan or
an NPR fan,
it's all going away if we don't buck up and beat these guys.
So we just went to fund anything.com forward slash pan trawl and you can give
toward the legal defense fund.
And that's video he's going,
there's
a video up there to watch where Adam explains the whole situation,
uh,
what's going on and,
and spread this,
spread it on Twitter,
spread it on Facebook.
Let everybody know.
If you can't donate,
at least spread the word and let people know what the fuck is going on.
Because,
uh,
yeah,
this is a crazy thing.
It's just a weird byproduct of our society,
right?
I don't like it,
but there's nothing we can do about it at this point in time.
No,
other than this,
that this,
it's really cool because this could be a seminal moment for podcasting,
which is you guys fucked with the wrong guys.
We're all grassroots,
but we all band together.
We all got our little individual little armies and we all got them United and we
all fought this common cause.
You know what I love about podcasting?
That I do think that that's something that fits with a,
the ethic of podcasting.
But I also love that podcasting isn't,
it's not a competitive thing in that everybody supports everybody else in
podcasting.
I've never heard of podcast feuds like morning Dj guys always fucking hate the
other morning Dj Guy,
right?
They always talk shit about him.
But podcasts,
I,
I've,
I don't know anybody who says like,
you know,
uh,
we would be fucking doing great if it wasn't for that Adam Carolla show.
Everybody's watching that stupid shows sucks our podcasts is the future that
shows for old people fuck up.
You know,
that doesn't,
it doesn't seem to be going on at all.
I think the Internet has,
the attitude of the Internet is that when you're dealing with the world,
you're dealing with an infinite amount of people.
It's so goddamn big that having that sort of famine mentality that a lot of
people have,
if they are in morning radio in a specific city,
you don't need it in the Internet.
No,
I listen to every,
I feel like,
uh,
you know,
the last podcast I did yesterday,
Jane Moore and Jo Koy were both guests on the show and they both have podcasts
and 80% of the guests on my show have their own podcast and we promote their
podcasts on my podcast.
Yes.
So that's all you need to know,
right?
Do the exact same thing.
And I'm always telling people,
you should do a podcast,
like people that have good guests.
I'm like,
why don't you do your own podcast all,
you don't even need a place like this.
He need a fucking MP,
three recorder and the microphone,
that's it.
Upload it online.
It takes 10 seconds and boom,
you have a fucking podcast.
Well,
plan and is podcasters unite?
Rally your army.
And let's beat this.
Let's do it.
We're in.
We're in 1000% that's not even a real number.
It's only a hundred percent is possible.
I had a liner in that,
but we'll say it.
That was like your hyperbole.
I liked that you liked it.
So fun.
anything.com forward slash patent troll,
please go there.
If you can't donate,
please spread the word so that other people can find out about it.
And that can donate.
I get it.
If you're broke,
I totally understand it.
But if you do,
uh,
appreciate podcasting and you do Adam's show and his network and he's got a
whole network.
And then on top of that,
everybody else that you know that does podcasts,
whether it's Joey [inaudible] or Duncan Trussell Adams,
right.
That would all go away if it wasn't for,
uh,
if you know,
if we can't figure out a way around this issue,
absolutely do it.
Do it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Adam,
I just want to tell you that you are one of the reasons why I did this in the
first place.
I loved watching you do it and go from regular radio.
And I remember doing the first ones when it was on the couch and you had the
clip on microphones and the whole deal.
I was like,
wow,
he's got kind of a cool setup here.
And that was part of what spun the wheels for me to get into this.
And the first person you were podcasting,
what time,
what year did you start?
The beginning of oh nine wasn't really.
Yeah.
So I was around slightly after you,
slightly after you,
but you're a,
I listen,
I'm flattered and even come on out and see the new digs whenever,
whenever you're like,
well,
how do you change anything?
Or you even bigger,
better now.
I always working on the studio,
always trying to improve and always trying to kind of build the business,
you know?
Well,
um,
it's a,
it's very cool.
It's very cool that it's working.
It's very cool to be a part of all this.
It's a,
the podcast and community is a great supportive community.
And what,
what you were talking about,
about having people on your show that you know,
that have their own podcast and promoting their podcasts.
I think that's one of the coolest things about this business really is.
Thanks John.
I appreciate it.
Adam Carolla,
lazy gentleman.
Follow him on Twitter and again,
go to what's the website?
One more time.
You got Adam carolla.com and find out everything you need to go to Adam
carolla.com.
Find out everything.
Go to rogan.ting.com to find out about ting and uh,
find out about the a iPhone five a giveaway.
Go to rogan.ting.com fill out the savings calculator.
See how much you'd save using Ting tweet,
how much you'd save two at Joe Rogan with the Hashtag [inaudible] and the winner
will be announced on Friday,
April 4th us residents only.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n,
n.
I.
T.
Use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
We'll be back in about a half an hour with the great honey honey band.
Please,
please donate to Adam's cause it's all of our cause.
Everybody help out if you can.
If you can't help out,
please promote it.
Thank you very much and see you soon.